check in on how the season is opening up
for the golden knights they are skating
over at city national chris matthews
joining us now with
more on how the season opening
preparations are going chris well thank
you denisha as the vega center's now his
fourth season boy it's exciting to think
the vegas golden knights one of the best
teams in the national hockey league
and that's a gold standard set by owner
bill foley there are a lot of reasons
this team would
cause other players in the league to be
a bit envious vegas has a stable full of
talent
they've signed some of the best top free
agents over the last three years
now can they live to the past remember
this a stanley cup final then a
post-season bid
last year another trip to the western
finals and this year
expectations soaring once again and
rightfully so
i don't think there's been too much
that's changed over the last few years
we've tweaked a few different systems um
but i think the identity
identity of this team hasn't changed um
you know i think that's given the
success over the last three or four
years so
we want that to continue and it all
starts from hard work so
i think that's one of the main focal
points we're trying to get to through
this camp
our cat continues until the start of the
season and the knights get a start at
home this year
their 56 game schedule begins january
14th
and that opener will be against the
anaheim ducks once again this season
the knights will be broadcast on a t
sports network brian chris thank you